oh good evening let me just
quickly introduce the event and and then
I'll turn it over to Alan Brinkley to
introduce professor Noreen
this is a course of a great event in the
academic year and and to have some of
our most distinguished faculty working
on some of the most interesting projects
and research come in and speak to the
community is the essence of what we do
and a great privilege and pleasure for
all of us
sherry there's a wonderful person to
listen to under any circumstances I am
sure that tonight it will be extremely
so he is sort of at the core of what we
all think of as important subjects of
globalization so biodiversity and and
death of species and life of species and
and ecology of the natural environment
and how that interacts with and
intersects with the human and other
parts of the environment it's always
just staggering to hear these statistics
about loss of species and the effects of
of that also staggering to hear
statistics about the degrees to which
were interconnected and I think we can
expect some of that but in the brief
conversation that we had before the
lecture I think we're in for a special
treat because he's going to take this to
almost everything that's in the news
today and we look forward to it great
things so Alan Provost
well it's I want to welcome all of you
here and it's really my pleasure this
evening to introduce Shahid Naima it's
tonight's university lecturer she had of
course is a is the professor in the
Department of Ecology evolution and
environmental biology universe
university lecturers are created in 1921
1971 excuse me to give distinguished
faculty an opportunity to address a
broad university audience and as Lee has
said Shahid is a very appropriate person
but to provide such a lecture since he's
not since he is an outstanding example
of a serious scientist who communicates
effectively to large audiences such as
the large and unseeded audience so we
have here today
Shahid came to Colombia in 2003 and
joined a department that was and still
is one of the university's smallest but
one could also say it is among our most
important departments because of the
great urgency of its mission d-iii be as
the department is known I is one of
Colombia's newest departments as well
and it's a product of the changing
character of what was once scientific
anthropology at Columbia and of the
indefatigable efforts of Don Melnick to
build a new department dedicated to
ecology and environmental biology which
would bring together environmental
biologists at Columbia with scientists
from other institutions in the New York
area through the center for
environmental research and conservation
known as Cirque Shi his arrival five
years ago was a critical moment in the
growth of de three-bean not only because
of his own leadership as chair of the
department over the last several years
and as head of an important laboratory
and not only because of his incredible
energy and commitment but also because
of the great significance of his work
Shahid describes his mission in a
powerful statement that sounds a little
like Lenin actually
that accompanies his description of his
research our group studies the ecology
consequences and ecological consequences
of declining biodiversity by whatever
means possible
we believe that changes in biodiversity
either through local extinction of
biological or biological invasions is
the single most important and dramatic
problem in contemporary ecology sure his
research has helped strengthen our
understanding of the relationship
between biodiversity and the future
ecology of the planet his work recently
published in a book that he has
co-edited biodiversity and ecosystem
functioning argues that human domination
of ecosystems is leading not just to a
loss of biodiversity but is posing a
danger to the stability of ecosystems
broadly throughout the planet columbia
is renowned for its broad commitment to
environmental and ecological scholarship
through the lamont-doherty Earth
Observatory the Department of Earth and
environmental science the Earth
Institute the School of International
and public affairs the School of Public
Health and many other parts of the
university but among the most important
elements of this great project is of
course the department that she had lead
leads and he has brought up to this vast
project a combination of scientific
rigor in pursuing his own important
research and also a calm but urgent
advocacy of the importance of continued
progress in our understanding of one of
the greatest challenges of our time so
please join me in welcoming Shahid
naheem Naeem who will deliver a lecture
entitled nature knowledge and our
national identity notes from an
increasingly lonely planet
well thank you and that's a lot to live
up to I'm not sure how to proceed in
fact when I was told I was going to have
the opportunity to do the University
lecture like most people when they're
told such such Awards that coming their
way
the first reaction is one of great sort
of pride and joy and then the next
reaction is oh my gosh what am I going
to say and so I've been dwelling on that
for for several months and and I
actually I actually got the idea of what
to talk about after I returned from a
summer of travel in China
Kenya Mali Tanzania trying to see how we
would take the science of ecology and
actually to put it to one of the
toughest problems we face which is
poverty alleviation it was quite a
challenge I have to say and I returned
back exhausted from from that summer of
travel and had to return for important
administrative event which got cancelled
and then had to be there to introduce
and welcome the new students to our
department the department that I chair I
gave the welcoming lecture to the class
of 2012 and then I had to teach
introductory biology horrible things
like the krebs cycle and protein
synthesis and so forth and so by the
time September 5th came came around I
was really ready for something different
and I got this email from an old friend
of mine and it reminds me of in Marcel
Proust of things past you know he has
the Madeleine he dips it in the tea and
it unleashes a large sort of set of
sensations that he then tracks back to
memories of his past and if you haven't
read that then you've probably seen the
movie ratatouille ok where the where are
Anton ego the the restaurant critic has
the ratatouille and it brings back
floods of his childhood in France and
this this was and what gave me the idea
of how to fill in this this title so you
see our department was named ecology
evolution and environmental biology
which allowed us to adapt to whatever
would come our way
so when I had to supply the title I
thought this would allow me to adapt to
whatever comes my way of course then you
have to live up to the expectations of
such a large title and I knew that I had
it there but it was actually this email
that was sent to me and it was from an
old friend and it was this attachment of
the New York Times a victory for Robert
Giroux was a man I never actually met
but he is someone who was very
influential in my thinking about the
world and about biodiversity as well
believe it or not now this was back in
the 1970s when I was really at the place
where I'd be interacting with Robert
Cheruiyot because he was one of the lead
editors in a firm called Fowler Straus
and Giroux I used to love answering the
phone Farrah Straus and Giroux what can
we do for you and I was I was just out
of high school and I was in an inventory
control which was the department that I
was and not my job was to balance the
supply of books with the demand which
was always really difficult when you had
people do silly things like win awards
because suddenly he'd be caught short in
my opinion as a youngster I felt that
this publishing firm was a very sleepy
place and the editors had eclectic
tastes and the seventy was a 70s was a
great period of transition in 1970 the
Nobel Prize was won by Alexander
Solzhenitsyn and his writing about the
The Gulag Archipelago for example and in
the what was going on in Russia the
former Soviet Union and Norman Borlaug
got the Nobel Prize as well for helping
to start the Green Revolution he was
supposed to be one of the people who
helped lead to practically a doubling of
food production in our world and he
actually was criticized by many people
for doing things which were not so good
for our environment and not so good for
the farmers and in many many people and
he was steadfastly a strong believer
that he had done the right thing so much
so he created the World Food Prize which
is given out to people who helped to
push the Green Revolution forward so
just to give you a sense of what the 70s
was like all your youngsters in the room
in nineteen
70 this is just 1970 The Beatles made
their last studio recording which was a
let it be Janis Joplin Janis Joplin had
died The Supremes gave their farewell
concert
now I'm the Chicago seven were acquitted
of charges of inciting a riot at the
Democratic National Convention we had
the first Earth Day we had four students
shot at Kent State Ohio and to students
at Jackson State for protests against
the Vietnam War which we were in the
thick of and we have the first New York
Marathon women marched down Fifth Avenue
for equality and the world population I
remember that the world population had
reached 3.7 billion and I remember it as
a youngster with my first job as an
inventory controller that we were also
in a recession so in case you can't see
the dates down that that's actually 1972
up to 1982 so in the so the time period
I'd be looking at is right around here
and you you see it's so sort of quaint
isn't it right now to be looking at an
index that goes from 200 to less than a
thousand and then we think oh my god
we're plummeting into a recession but
you can see there was a sort of steady
growth and all of a sudden due to a weak
economy and a number of other factors
the investment in the things in the
united united states for the trying to
improve our well-being the vietnam war
in which we were fighting a war against
insurgents in which our great military
technology seemed to be of no use to us
sounds sounds familiar and and then
there was an energy crisis in that time
in that point at that time created by an
oil and embargo from the opec oil cartel
to sort of show us their their power
combined all of that together and we
went into a into a recession and sort of
sort of bopped around in that recession
for for quite some time some people
refer to that period of stagflation
because we had inflation in a sort of a
stagnant economy that didn't seem to be
going anywhere okay so I wanted Farah
Strauss and drew which was my employer
to make money right and enough with
these eclectic authors that that Giroux
would would be hiring and hiring but
would be giving the opportunity to
publish their works at fast trust and
Giroux and you know it's very hard to
get booked data so I did what most
people do Li's amazon.com to get a track
of how books are sold and the reason
that's a good thing is because they sell
about 150,000 books a day which is
pretty impressive but their crush their
one bookseller so it's a bit biased but
I wanted to show you what which is where
I got the idea for this talk this
particular graph I was told not to show
graphs but I think this is a much more
sophisticated audience than usual so I
hope you'll put it with my bivariate
bought and amazon.com ranks books they
actually have a number one book in a
number one book would be a book that
would be selling almost 3000 copies a
day but it plummets dramatically come
from the by the time that you are ranked
number 10 you're selling a mere 500 now
I can tell you my volume I'd be lucky if
we sold just a few you know it's an
academic volume a few copies we're
probably I have I don't dare to look up
the rank of my edited volume it's down
here someplace I'm sure but see Giroux
was really pushing for authors in this
sort of area and I wanted the company to
make money so we would get out of the
wage price freeze that had been invoked
by our beloved president back then and
and I thought why don't we go for these
bestsellers well let me show you at
least currently you know what sort of
books they would be so here's the
current list unfortunately made this
last week kind of distressing actually
to see how fast it changes but I thought
if we could get these sorts of books
like Obama's two books you may notice
not surprisingly are in the top ranked
here so that's selling quite a book
quite a bit the second book last week
was a io USA by Wigan encontrar and
Walker and says it's a lively and
entertaining romp through the four
deficits the nation faces the budget
deficit the personal savings deficit the
trade deficit and leadership deficit and
okay then then there's the shack which
is called another God meets guy book you
can read now that is and much to my
surprise these four books are all by
Stephanie my
there the Twilight series I really like
how they describe this great love
stories thrive on sacrifice throughout
the Twilight Saga which is a series of
books Stephenie Meyer is writing she has
tried to emulate these great love
stories this is from Publishers Weekly
Romeo and Juliet weathering Heights okay
but in this case it is the faded yet
perpetually doomed love a Bella the
human girl and Edward the vampire it is
remarkable but all four of these books
sadly this morning well I should though
that I just showed my prejudice actually
interestingly this morning I discovered
that these four books are now in the top
and the Obama books have a sank down so
I thought I would look at Romeo and
Juliet there many different editions out
this was the best-selling one which is
ranked at number six thousand seven
hundred and you see it's very hard to
actually see how many books that's
actually selling and then if we look at
weathering Heights again the best issue
of the weathering Heights that's selling
or the bet highest ranked it's ranked
number fifteen thousand two hundred
eighty six and I think my volume on
biodiversity ecosystem functioning
probably has an even lower one the we
can look at the New York Times and it's
still sort of interesting in that you
know they had last week Nelson DeMille
the great house which I I won't I won't
go into in too much detail it's says
that the plot more more than takes its
time getting to its violent and
predictable resolution but the middle
devotee should have plenty of fun along
the way
Dewey is about a cat that was stuffed
into I think the mailbox of a library in
Iowa and the librarians adopted and it's
all about how we can learn from Dewey
so pussycat and uh so that I've decided
to say these were the books that that
rock that um that guru was interested in
you know the ones that would win the
Nobel Prizes the one that would win the
ones that would win the Pew leeches and
the ones that would win the National
Academy of National Academy there's
there's my mind um where's the win the
National Book of wars and so I won't
bother going in through those to those
details but I thought we are never going
to make it if we don't get the books
about the Pussycats of course I would I
would mature from then I think what you
what what I noticed then as I do now is
actually abstractly this particular
curve it's the it's the law of normal
so here I'm showing you a bunch of
curves n' and it's something that I
think dominates science is a very very
interesting phenomenon as much as it is
for ecologists as it is to economists
social scientists and physicists and
chemists and engineers this is the
normal distribution in which you have
some sort of average and then you have
some things which are above the average
and some things which are below so there
might be a mean height and this in very
tall people and some very short people
but in fact most of the world doesn't
really seem to be represented by this
sort of normal distribution it's
represented more by something called the
log normal distribution where it's
always skewed where there always seems
to be some number of things which have a
value and many many things which have
values lower than that in fact it's very
strongly skewed thing here reflects I
think what we saw in the in the typical
book sale figures there are a few books
which are very very common and then
there are massive books which are very
very rare and I always remembered that
sort of that idea about Communists and
rarity once I became an ecologist back
to my days in the 70s when I was in the
book business because this sort of idea
comes to you when you wander around the
world as I started to do more and more
now these are just if you were to take a
walk with me in New York near Black Rock
forest for example you would see these
creatures I'm sure you recognize quite
quite readily and if you look closely as
I do you'd see lots of different species
down on the ground that might not catch
your attention unless you look closely
but as you walk more and more and start
travel to other countries maybe get out
of New York which I know is a rare thing
to do for many of us go to Minnesota
which is where I had actually had my
first professorial position the same
place where Norman Borlaug actually he
was in the building next to us and
started to see a new set of species that
were there this was a day that
dragonflies had emerged I'd been there
for seven years and hadn't seen that I'm
now working in Inner Mongolia on the
grasslands in China along with my
students and saw a Siberian Iris
wandering through Texas the the
Dominican Republic I was only in
Dominican Republic for about a week and
saw an extraordinary number of species
for such a tiny island state the sense I
got as I was
around is that the more you explore the
more species you will see that might
seem somewhat trivial at first but it
did make me realize that if you don't
have a chance to get out and explore you
will not actually get an appreciation
for the diversity of life that is out
there and I became more and more
interested although as a cell biology
major as as an undergraduate at UC
Berkeley in this phenomenon of the great
diversity of life that was out there
which I found studying the molecular
biology of the cell was less and less
satisfying for it's a beautiful little
sort of micro fungi in Costa Rica and
this this the these perennial acute
little frogs many of which are imperiled
here's a mama duck and her babies in New
Zealand and some of these species might
be familiar to you they might resonate
with you you might feel like ah there's
my child going off to college and then
you know the snake might strike fear in
your heart this is a hornbill that's
actually feeding its mate that was
living inside that tree and then this
was when I was in Chile and I just
thought this creature has the ideal life
if you ask me and you can see it on its
smug little face and the interesting
thing about this actually in an abstract
way is something that's called the
species area curve or the species area
relationship it's got a very simple
equation I thought don't people said
don't put equation stuff but I thought
we could put up with this one since it's
so phenomenon and what it says it it's
so simple it's so easy to follow what it
says is that the number of species is
basically a function of some constant
here in the area in which you've done
your exploration to find those species
and then raised to the power of this
power law or which is a constant and it
turns out that whether you're looking at
plants or microbes where they were
looking at insects or mammals no matter
what you're looking at very very often
it comes to about 0.25 and there's no
reason for that to be the case and this
puzzle has actually has possessed
ecologist for a long time because it
suggests that nature is not randomly
structured it actually has almost a
universal law to it because this kind of
relationship is something you see in
many many other fields as well so if we
were to look at the earth
and imagine that the number of species
was about 30 million my favorite
estimate for the total number of species
and say that the area that you could
explore was five hundred and ten million
square kilometers if you don't leave
your house that's pretty easy you won't
see any species but if you get out even
just a little you'll see a lot but it
does take a tremendous amount of effort
for you to go and see all of those
species that are out there and to tell
you the truth we only have about two
million which have actually been
formally described by scientists and a
smaller number millions more than might
be known but not formally described I
want to give you an example just to
convince you that this is in fact a very
active area research this is in 2000 by
Plotkin at all and here they're looking
at the distribution abundance of trees
inside five different tropical
rainforests all across the world and I'm
going to show you another graph you can
ignore this one on the bottom here but
as you can see from their publication
the Proceedings of the National Academy
of Science that as they increase the
area of investigation for the forests
they were looking at they found that the
number of species of trees they
encountered went up and then it leveled
off now you notice that their curves
there are different heights but they all
have the same shape
that's that C equals approximately 0.25
now I want to go back and show you the
extraordinary effort this took we're
looking here at two hundred and thirty
five thousand tree species made up of
three hundred and five trees sorry made
up of three hundred five species here
seventeen thousand trees made up of
sixty sixty eight species here we have
three hundred and thirty nine thousand
trees made up of one thousand one
hundred and seventy one species this is
not easy data to get but it's incredibly
valuable because it tests the idea about
whether nature is random or it's not and
it's not random it's very very highly
structured and I became fascinated by
that as many ecologists have in fact the
broken stick model by Brock Arthur one
of the more well known ecologist back in
the 70s the log normal by Preston in the
1950s Robert Fischer's alpha PV is the
famous sir Fisher a statistician who
came up with a way of describing this
and here we have these youngsters
Plotkin at all actually
young or not but they're new
contributors to the field and they claim
that they have an even better model
because you see their model is the
yellow line and the data go through that
yellow line much better than these other
seems like every few years we get a new
theory and I think if you want to be
very successful in ecology you have to
address this question why is nature so
non-random so Frank Preston in 1948 was
the first to actually sort of give us a
formal explanation for why that occurred
I won't go into that too much detail
there isn't time here but be happy to
talk to if you want to come by any day
and give you and talk about why people
think this occurs but you can see but
just like the books I was talking about
there are a number of species here which
have very very low densities whenever
you go out and sample them so here
looking at the species that they found
in a particular set of moths I believe
yes he's a female moths picked up at a
trap there are numbers of species that
had only one individual number of
species which had - some of the species
had 8,192 individuals for a single
species and what you notice you see the
title of his his paper very classic
paper in ecology is communist and rarity
of species he points out that nature is
really defined by many many species
which are rare just like many many books
which are not the best sellers out there
but nevertheless are quite important to
our our culture on there many species
out there as well but the world is often
dominated by a few species we seem to be
fairly common and there's no reason
there's absolutely no reason for that to
be the case so this log normal
distribution is well worth exploring
as I said you know if you look at it
some of you might say well I don't know
maybe it's just a sort of strange way
about that how the universe works I'll
give you some examples the number of
letters per words shows a log normal
distribution the number of words per
sentence the length of words and
diversity of words follow log normal
distributions the age of marriage farm
size and nepo demonology the latency of
disease I have a list of examples here
that I'm reading from the sizes of
particles in a pile of sand or the sizes
of meteorites that hit our planet they
all show log normal distributions I
would argue that we should throw out the
Gaussian distribution is start to think
more about log normal distributions
because that's where the rare species
and that's where the rare things start
to matter so
so to me I think it was an interesting
thing to start to you know many many
years later as a graduate student
ecology to discover what I learned in
the working world of publishing these
commonalities about our knowledge base
our books our literature our nonfiction
and fiction and our species and how they
how they were distributed now Preston
interestingly had noticed as many
scientists have there many articles
about this that the log normal
distribution actually applies to many
things and here he's pointing out how it
points to it it actually explains some
of the gas laws and what he calls wealth
laws and interestingly he shows that if
you look at the the distribution of
wealth and here he's looking at wealth
in the in 1926 I believe he's showing
that there's actually an extraordinary
number of small there's extraordinarily
small number of people who make an awful
lot of money and then there's an awful
lot of a number of people who make very
very little money and he argue that you
know that's actually pretty much the
same sort of distribution for energy
that you see in particles in an ideal
gas and and then he goes on to say that
the log normal distribution is I just
said is something that seems quite
common throughout the the universe
what's interesting he ends his article
almost suggesting that we shouldn't buck
against this maybe that maybe the
natural order of things is to have a few
people with lots of money and many many
people I can't believe he said that but
I imagine that since he he he published
out of a laboratory which was called the
Frank W Preston laboratories he may have
been one of those people in the other
end of that this appeared in the
Atlantic Monthly and I once again my
life seems possessed by these log normal
distributions I said Wow take a look at
that and this was a way of actually
trying to illustrate that in a more
graphic way and the the idea is imagine
that there's a parade of people and that
the people's height is actually
represented by the proportion of wealth
that they actually op they actually own
so if we were to start at this end of
the parade here for sis to be the end of
the parade you know this would be the
ninety nine point nine nine fifth
percentile the individual would be nine
hundred and thirty three feet tall so
we're just seeing the
shoes and the individual goes way up
there someplace well above the the
campus and then as soon as you get to
the 99.9 fifth percentile we drop down
to them to to a very short 181 feet and
then when you get down to the 97th
percentile we get down to the 21 foot
person and if you actually look at the
entire parade this is what the parade
would look like so actually we'd start
out here and as the author points out at
the beginning of the parade you wouldn't
see anybody because they'd actually be
underground there but their heads would
be below the ground because they
actually owe people money or their being
there being subsidized in one way
another and then we have all of these
people be a long long long parade and
then you'd get to the end and like boom
all the wealthy people would go by very
very quickly and this is as you can see
it log a beautiful beautiful log normal
distribution in and of course and this
came up a lot during the recent election
the debates about you know how who we
would tax what's the base and so forth
and of course in our country I think we
recognize that everybody here plays a
role but this wealth distribution is
something that we're quite familiar with
the article argues however that the
wealth distribution is much more skewed
than you would expect and I'll leave you
to read that article - to learn more
about that my main point is that you can
see that it fits a lot of a lot of
things that that we know about the world
so I know I want to talk about some just
a couple of examples because there isn't
very much time about the science that I
do but I wanted to start out by by
acknowledging in case I forget that I'm
a chair I don't really do very much I
sort of write the grants and try to
stimulate people to write papers and go
out and get grants and fellowships and
things like that and so you know really
it's my lab and this is my lab here we
are enforcing the laws of nature where
we can you know I think that if you have
talked to any scientist they recognized
that their life is really defined by the
by the postdocs and the and the students
that surround them graduate and
undergraduate
well and and we have a lot of fun in
spite of the fact that the the subject
that we're tackling could be in some
have used quite grim you may have
noticed in the in the introductions by
by by Lee and Alan that there was a lot
of sort of boy we're tackling this
really grim thing the death of life as
we know it in Salford and you know I I
actually haven't said anything about
that in fact I seem somewhat happy don't
I I mean I I've been determined to take
the you know to find a way to put a sort
of humorous spin on the demise of our
world as we know it and and I think I'm
not explaining why that is if I can if I
can get to everything I'd like to talk
to you at the very end as to why I take
that tactic but the very first paper I
did this was back when I was a postdoc
in England and we worked on this machine
called the eco Tron and we knew the
power of naming something like that and
this is an ordinary person she is not
one of the wealthiest people who is 7900
and 30 feet tall she's an ordinary
person and she's measuring here light
inside different the vegetation in
different heights this is a community
that we built of many different species
and then we built a variety of other
communities which had fewer and fewer
species in them so as everytime he moved
to a different chamber in the e-tron
there were sixteen chambers you would
find that there were smaller numbers of
species and we actually asked the
question what would happen if you were
to lose biodiversity and believe in a
lot in 1994 that was the first time that
anybody had ever asked that question
trust postdocs who don't know any better
to say gosh you know nobody's asked that
question why don't we try it out and
there are about 10 of us who worked on
the project and five of us authored the
paper that came out of nature and much
to our surprise it became the fifth most
cited paper in global change research
shortly after its publication we all got
jobs so we did the right thing which is
important I'd hate to be mercenary about
it but um we were surprised I think
because we thought well of course
wouldn't you expect that the more
diversity you have the better an
ecosystem would be the more carbon it
would store the more toxins it would it
would it would detoxify the more
pollutants it would degrade the more
stable it would be to seem like you know
the goodness of species was something
one would
question and yet we were surprised when
I went to see why you know if it had
become one of the most widely cited
papers you never want to do that because
you'll find out that about half of the
citations were this one another bit of
rubbish this was and and but my
professor we know told me he said that
you always want to work on something
that's controversial that's where the
excitement is don't work on something
that's boring and boy did we step into
something that turned out to be fairly
controversial so we you know tip to you
to quiet things down we put out a stall
defying academic symposium volume which
i think is still being published I don't
know it's academic rank and we have
another one that should be coming out
next year which is going to try to quiet
the masses about this and yet all we
wanted to say in that in that in that
volume authored by many many people all
of them who've been very successful now
psychologists and and in fact one of one
of my um one student like co-authored a
paper with not my student just got a job
at Stanford which was the job I was
denied when I had interviewed haha I
look back I don't know a long long time
ago that person got tenure and left so I
thought oh my job has opened up again
but of course I'm senior now and then I
found out that my student I co-authored
a paper with got that job so this is a
very active field and it's a lot of fun
I don't have time to go into the
research and great t-tail and you'd
probably get sleepy if I did but I
didn't want to show you paper that
actually came out of Columbia by Dan
Bunker here and for briefs to clerk for
breezes and Earth Institute fellows
they're wonderful people who brought
here by the ther Institute to help sort
of mix things up at the University and
Dan bunker is now he was my postdoc alas
he is now an assistant professor at the
New Jersey Institute of Technology
I say alas because it's so useful having
postdocs around they do grow up after a
while and he did this remarkable work
where we gathered as much data as we
could are such as say they did for a
patch of tropical rainforest and ask
questions about how much carbon could
that far store and the conclusion we
came with is that the answer to that
very very important question in an age
of climate warming because of all that
co2 than yet that's in the atmosphere
and we want to know how much carbon can
be stored in that forest was very very
dependent on the number of species and
the kind of speed
that was in there not only was the
quantity of carbon that could be stored
important in terms of the diversity of
the forest but also the sort of
reliability of that forest for storing
your carbon so you might imagine that if
you have money that you want to put into
a bank which right now you might be
hesitant to do but if you did you would
want to find a bank that was going to be
there for a long time was going to give
you sort of reliable storage of your
your accounts and if we wanted to use
forest to be our banks for storing
carbon you would want to get one that
actually does not only a good job but
also does a stable job of it and that's
what our argument was say this think he
rapidly became another very widely cited
paper because it brought biodiversity
into the carbon market I just wanted to
show you this because you know molecular
biologist cells throw out their
three-dimensional graphs that rotate and
they would take a long time explain to
this I think he just supposed to be
impressed that we can do this as a
colleges there as well ok you know what
what I would do is I would say you know
if you have any questions ask me
afterwards but but primarily what my lab
did was you know I put the challenge
before them to try to come up with a new
way of quantifying diversity and we came
up with a relatively up to term for it
and we came up with a way of defining
diversity in a way that would actually
track its its value in terms of what it
does for us in terms of things like
storing carbon or detoxifying toxins or
degrading pollutants and now I want to
show you the study we've done most
recently it's still in manuscript form
so please don't rush out and try to
publish it Brenda Lin who is the postdoc
who led this and my entire lab is
involved in it this is a set of prairie
stamps put out by they got my work in
the prairie in Minnesota for a long time
right next to Norman Borlaug worked into
turning the Prairie into corn fields and
we had a chance to sit back and ask
questions about what would happen to our
world here's the challenge that you know
we sort of face this is the American
Great Plains one of the most beautiful
places in in the world at least back
when it looked like this in my opinion
and you know you can still find places
where there a few bison roaming until
they hit a fence and if you would
explore the the grasslands there you
would probably find that it has this
extraordinary sort of diversity of
plants and animals
there are cultural and aesthetic and
other sorts of reasons for valuing that
but I wanted to take as we did in our
lab a more sort of practical view what
are the consequences of taking this and
turning it into this where we still have
grazing animals albeit cattle and and we
still have grasses there aren't herds of
bison actually sort of cut it all up and
then we feed them and feed Lots that's
how we manage it these days and now
there's only 1% of the prairies left and
that amazing we're always worried about
the disappearance of the rainforest
we're always worried about disappearance
of other habitats and other countries
yet here in our own country our most
beautiful habitat the American prairie
only 1% of it is left that has all been
turned into this what you know my my um
my spouse is from Wisconsin was really
disappointed when I was traveling
through Wisconsin and really had nothing
poetic to say about this this habitat
because if you grow up in this landscape
it's actually in your own eyes a
beautiful landscape and it says
something about the strength of our of
our species in its ability to to wrestle
from the earth the resources we need to
make a good living and the question that
we had is sort of phrased by this sort
of abstract picture here we wanted to
know if the capacity of our agricultural
landscape which replaced the Prairie is
actually less than the capacity that
used to be there is that a contraction
so the green here would represent our
native hull as its call I'll explain why
that is if you want later but you can
get the sense that the up the
alternative in many people might feel
this is true is that the agricultural
landscape is actually much more useful
and diverse and powerful as an as an
ecological system because soybean corn
wheat and cattle are much more resilient
and robust species than the pathetic
bison in prairie grasses that used to be
there the other possibility is that both
the same they've just been displaced a
little bit because I want to shift in
another is is is that you know we may
have such a displacement that they're
two completely different worlds and I
want to show you what the analysis was
and I think it's really a shocking
result and also beautiful in its own way
here's our nice three-dimensional
rotating graph I think you can sort of
get a sense here that this represents
the
American prairie in the Great Plains
that used to be there in the ecological
capacity what that means is that if
there was a drought if there was a fire
if there was a wet wet time or a flood
this kind of grassland here was very
very robust and very very likely to show
some ability to survive under those
changing conditions this is our
agricultural system not only does it
have very very little capacity to adapt
to those sorts of changes it's also a
completely different world this is the
brave new world that we live in and it's
a question we might ask about whether or
not this is something that makes you
comfortable or makes you worried so now
let's catch us up to where we are today
so this is probably looks too familiar
to everybody even if you didn't pay
attention to the Dow Jones before you
now see it on the news all the time and
it's sort of it's sort of interesting
now to be up here above 10,000 right
actually to say you know back in the 70s
when we were below in thousand and to
watch you know dropping from from from a
very very high to a low value something
that worries us people are not quite
sure where it's going to bottom out and
we're concerned we're getting memos from
the President and from the probe from
the vice president about how we should
tighten our belts here at the University
and and and we've been there before my
father-in-law's in the audience and has
been through the depression and he'll
tell you you know we survived and you
just had to tighten your belt that's a
message he he continues to deliver to us
and and I think maybe we'll heat him a
bit more now than we have living in New
York and I wanted to show you what is
happening now since 1970 and this is
where you know it might get sort of
depressing this is a living Planet Index
this report came out just a couple of
weeks ago it's the 2008 Living Planet
report and it tells you the state of
biodiversity if you believe their index
their index is based on about 5,000
populations of vertebrates mostly and it
sort of it collects the information on
how they are trending are they trending
down or how they trending up and there's
probably about 1800 I think species
there in the
I don't have the numbers before me but
it's roughly in that that sort of
category the idea is that if we keep
track of fish and birds
that's about 1,600 species of mammals
and birds and reptiles so there are no
insects or anything like that in here
but you can see that you know in 1970
we're not sure if things were getting
better because we were actually setting
up more parks or conservation biology
was growing or whether we're just
getting more and more data about more
species out there but it's clear that
right here as we got into the 1990s that
things started to go downward and
started to go downward at an alarming
rate and if you look at these two other
indices one which is called the
ecological footprint and the other which
is called world biocapacity the
ecological footprint sort of tells you
how much it is we need to consume what
are the resources that each individual
would need in this case we're actually
asking about the entire human population
and they're saying here that if you
consider that the world was able to
provide those needs and we standardized
that to one that somewhere in the
mid-1980s back at the height of yuppie
dung we wound up crossing that where we
are now meeting what is it about 1.4
planets to supply what is currently
consumed or need needed by by our
population so the when the press release
for this this Living Planet report was
the real credit crunch and the credit
crunch we really have to worry about
which I thought was a nice way of trying
to capture this this study force of the
press to understand and here it is again
I thought wow look at that there's
another log normal distribution don't
you love log normal distributions I
think I'm going to start a collection of
them this is the bio capacity and of
course you can see you might might try
to guess where we are this is telling us
in a single acre of land that an
individual might live you know how much
how much support are they going to find
so the units here let's cut off a little
bit at the top there but it tells you
what the cut the bio capacity is
available per person and its measured in
hectare so if you're a person in Gabon
your country hazard men
this amount of biocapacity however if
you if you go down this list here Canada
has a lot about capacity has a capacity
of supporting each of its individuals
very very well when you get down to the
United States we're still above this
this line here but you'll notice that
the line the the the bar is red and gets
increasingly red if the reason you're by
capacity is actually high is because
it's being subsidized so we're actually
importing food from a lot of other
countries so our bio capacity is
actually sort of inflated by the fact
that we import a lot of our resources
and if you look at the ecological
footprint you'll see that in contrast we
are right up there with the United Arab
Emirates in terms of the number of
hectares it takes in the world to
support a single individual there's that
line where we would like not to cross
and you can see I don't know if that's
something I could you know go America go
once again we topped the world in
exceeding the bio capacity of our own
home country it's interesting to take a
look at these because if you contrast
that with the fact that we looked at a
log normal distribution for species and
most of our species are rare yet they're
very important to the way our ecosystems
work which is the studies I showed you
and you look at wealth distribution now
you look at these ecological
distributions in terms of footprint and
by capacity it gives you a picture of
the way our world looks today and this
this one here is broken down by sort of
large geographic regions which shows you
that there are still some regions of the
world where the bio capacity hasn't been
exceeded
but there are other places where it has
and it's interesting to think about if
we are trying to pursue this new path of
sustainable development how we might
take into consideration by capacity and
ecological footprint into those
deliberations and try to do that okay so
we get back to these little these these
these little creatures big and small to
me it seems that when we are going out
and looking at bio capacity when we're
going out and looking at ecological
footprint we forget about what our
studies are increasingly showing that
these species which we have some sort of
cultural value for there are lots of
reasons we might want to conserve them
independent of what they do in terms of
those ecosystem services they provide us
I enjoy going out just to see them but I
also look at them and I say these are
the workers they're the they're the
little ones in that long parade that are
working 24/7 for us to make our planet
livable and yet no one is particularly
taking them into our considerations
about how we're going to try to deal
with the rapid changes we're seeing in
our world is not cute you don't really
want to curl up with them but these are
all features that that you know again
that I have taken as I've wanted the
world mostly because I find them
fascinating but also because I'm amazed
at the diversity of life that's out
there that creates that bio capacity
that tells us whether or not we're going
to be able to stay in balance and so
then you travel and this was where I was
in the summer and I came back exhausted
and I got that strange email on
September 5th that made me think about
all this
because when I was in in in and the
Craig's I think are going to see the
same sort of experience here on Kenya at
a millennium village that's one of the
earth Institute's millennium villages
where they're trying to see if they can
find a way to take the idea or the
theory of sustainable development and
try to achieve poverty alleviation and I
as an ecologist and trying to bring the
science of ecology into those sorts of
activities I have to confess it's quite
a challenge you see these you see these
these people and they remind us of
ourselves they're you know the they
they're they're they're full of energy
they're full of enthusiasm they're full
of ideas and and they're very they're
struggling and yet when I go around I'm
not quite sure how exactly we can begin
to take our science only because we've
just started it's a little late to start
this and try to get them out of the
poverty trap that they've been I've been
stuck in here's a Columbia undergraduate
helping them devise a healthcare system
kind of like our other Columbia graduate
who's been doing that in the in the
nation right now and this is Pedro
Sanchez who is winner of the World Food
Prize and the MacArthur Genius award in
you know the Norman Borlaug had set that
up a long long time ago and it was a
pleasure to meet I have endless
discussions with him I have to say we
argue quite a bit but we agree on many
things as well and this is the farmer of
that area who came out to greet him and
I I stood back and and watched as these
people gathered on
Hill to listen to the translator
translate the conversation between the
farmer and Pedro is asking questions
about this the the wisdom of growing
cotton the farmer thinks it's a very bad
idea why they're growing the crops they
grow the sort of tillage practices they
take and there is a there's a PhD or
masters and an undergraduate
all from Columbia that I'm back there
holding the camera and there's Cheryl
pom I think that Columbia as is not
atypical is taking the lead in trying to
take the science that we do social and
natural science and try to bring it to
some real-world problem-solving and
ecologists have a bit of sort of ketchup
ketchup to do now one thing I might say
as long as they're talking about
Columbia to return back to the to the
publishing world and our participation
is that I told Allen Allen probably
thought I was just trying to flatter him
but but it's actually my job as a chair
to actually lock horns with him whenever
possible it says that in the handbook
actually and but I read this I was
reading a long series of very very short
articles about the future of the
American idea and there I just want to
read it to you says there may be room to
redefine how we exercise leadership but
we could embrace elements of the
American idea that have in the past and
might again make the United States not
just a feared military power but an
exemplar of ideals a potentially
universal appeal because human rights
environmental responsibilities and a
commitment to peace and stability as a
precondition of progress and indeed
survival was right there of course
environmental responsibilities mixed in
with human rights and a commitment to
peace and stability which I think
defines school of international public
affairs the earth Institute our
department the Department of Earth and
environmental science has so many
different factions I have to say when I
came here and people said that I want to
join a department that had two faculty
in it and leave a department that had an
entire building at Seattle when I
wandered around and met the people here
in a Plamondon also the American Museum
in the New York Botanical Garden and the
Wildlife Conservation Society I realized
this was the happening place we're
really the sort of start up for this new
sort of view you know and I think that
we have at the root of the American
people a genuine fondness for our
habitat
witnessing these postal stamps that come
out every year there's the Prairie
always you know you can also see how the
postal rates keep rising but I have a
loved to see these when they come out
there aren't people in here but they do
show that I think America does have a
great appreciation for all the species
that that are out there and what we'll
do if we decide that we will become the
environmental the leader for
environmental stewardship as our new
national identity which I think we
should do because that will be the
biggest crisis our planet faces is the
environmental crunch the real credit
crunch as the Living Planet report says
right now so what are we going to do
people also never say what it is I think
we should do I think this is what we
should do right now we have these sorts
of websites that can tell you about the
birds and about the Tree of Life and
about the Diptera so they want to go
find out about flies and then if you
want to find about the South American
cichlids or this new thing which year
Wilson is sub spearhead I think there's
something like 10 million dollars from
the MacArthur Foundation and two million
dollars from the sloan foundation to
make a webpage for every single species
described we got an NSF grant to
actually do a more scientific venture
it's only about half a million which is
not enough but we want to build a
prototype of a new kind of computer a
service called trait bank named after
the modeled after GenBank
I won't go into the details but we're
very excited about this we had our first
meeting here in December last year and
we were overwhelmed by what it is we
want to do to give you a sense of what
it is we want to do take out your iPhone
and you might imagine that if you look
closely down on it that there would be
an app as they are called that you would
download called biodiversity and that if
you clicked on that app that it would
actually you know locate where you are
with the GPS unit and then you could
actually if you didn't want it I think
wouldn't be too interesting looking at
biodiversity in Manhattan we do have a
red-tailed hawk that lives outside of
our apartment but you know we might
scoot down and I'm only gonna do this
because I have a number of photos and I
know you can do this I have webcams that
my bird feeders in our house near Black
Rock forest and I can actually you can't
see it now because the talk I look at
the birds at my bird feeder on my iPhone
so I know you can do this if you just
get enough resources to make it happen
so here we are zooming in in the
Dominican Republic because I was there
and I have lots of photos of it and then
we can you know turn it into his natural
habitat and then after that we would be
able to say we want to look for the
spiders because we've come across a
spider were curious about the spider
diversity that's there I happen to have
lots of pictures but there are lots of
spiders in Dominican Republic otherwise
I would have done something else and
then you would further click and then if
you really cared about it which I don't
you could get the systematics in great
detail already but then I think you'd
really want to know more about you know
what's there trophic level what do they
feed on how many species are what the
population what the biomass of the
individual is so we could actually
figure out what those things in the tail
of the distribution are doing for the
environment of the Dominican Republic
and then you know if you went you could
go and get the Dow Jones if you wanted
to but you could also get the latest
readings for the bio capacity in the
ecological footprint for that country
and you could also get the Nightfort net
primary productivity and it seems like
this is sort of a fantasy world but yet
if you think about and if you know the
science design my students and postdocs
and colleagues know we think it's just a
matter of a few years before we might
actually be able to do that I think that
you know we really should at the end of
the news broadcast find out not just
what the Dow Jones is but also what the
latest status on biocapacity NECA
logical footprint are so there's a lot
to do should be a lot of fun as well
and the technology and the resources I
think are there so you may wonder why it
is that I am I just wanted to show you
these these shy deer and this dove
that's returning this is in Colorado
here my favorite favorite trees the
Bristlecone pine with their roots bound
to the slopes there there's some of the
oldest creatures on the world the
dolphins these are people in Australia
were actually paid money just I have to
come the Dolphins come up to them and
take fish from their hand and we thought
it was so much fun Sarah and I went and
paid money to do it as well because it
was really a lot of fun so I want to
read this this poem to you which
unfortunately is a very tiny print but
just explained as my last comment why it
is I don't feel that we should we should
take a look at this in any other way
than a positive way that we can do
something about the changes in our
planet so this is this is a poem called
advice to advice to a prophet by a
graves I'm not a prophet but by any
means but but you know he says that he's
talking about I think sort of the
environmental prophets of doom in this
case it was the prophets of nuclear
annihilation which I think was far just
as serious back in a long time ago but
he says I'm just going to read it to you
Matt I'd from stating the obvious
not proclaiming our fall but begging us
in God's name to have self pity spare us
all word of the weapons their force and
ranged the long numbers that rocket the
mind our slow unreconciled to have fear
what is too strange I don't really see
that there is much to be gained by
starting out with the number of species
that are going extinct the change in the
amount of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere the receding shorelines the
emerging diseases although I said I
don't really see the point of doing that
I see that I'm now actually listing all
the terrible reasons why you should not
go to sleep tonight but um it says you
know that that you shall not scare nor
shall you scare us with talk of the
death of the race how should we dream of
this place without us the Sun mere fire
the leaves untroubled about us a stone
look on a stones face um speak of the
world's own change but we cannot
conceive of a nun dreamt thing we know
to our cost how the dreamt cloud
crumbles how the vines are blackened by
frost and and and it goes on to say that
we could we could believe if you told us
so that the white-tailed deer will slip
into perfect shade-grown perfectly shy
the lock avoid the reaches of our eye
the Jackpine lose its knuckled grip on
the cold ledge and every torrent burn a
xanthus once it's gliding strout's
stunned in a twinkling what should we be
with
the Dolphins Ark the doves return these
things in which we have seen ourselves
and spoken Tom goes on that's why I
think that if you look at nature and you
have a sense of how rich it is and you
understand that although these species
are rare they are as important as we are
I think none of us are actually we're
all in that long part of the parade of
humanity these are in the long parade of
our natural ecosystems I think that you
know to imagine that these things are
not going to be there one day certainly
something that can get us all tragic and
you know teary eyed and worried about
certainly I get choked up when I think
that if I were to walk next year and the
after that the planet is getting
increasing increasingly lonelier and I
feel that actually because you have to
walk longer and harder to find those
species um but more importantly I
recognize that if we lose our friends
and our companions in this world who are
working with us to make the world a
better place and mind you they don't
belong to any unions they don't have
held any health benefit plans that
nevertheless all of us have exactly the
same sorts of goals which is to make the
world a better place for us to live in
then there is a reason to look at
biodiversity but it's a tremendous
amount of sense of purpose and of
optimism about what we can do
I think our department one of the
reasons I like although our departments
the struggle going into our department
and seeing all the young people there is
that their attitude about it is that
something can be done and the world is
changing in spite of what our
generations have done to it in the past
and they are dogged ly determined in
spite of the fact that we have among the
largest numbers of credits required to
anybody and we are second to chemistry
in terms of how hard we ding them on
their GPA they still come to us we have
about 40 brave souls who are majored in
art in our department and are going to
go out and make the world a better place
as well all of you so thank you very
much for indulging my pleasure
I
I probably run way over but I have one
last one last thing to do so I said it
was my duty at the care
but I have to recognize that I saw that
Alan had decided it's going to God
entity to do other thing to not be
Provost in the park that at least during
his tenure our program has really
flourished we have
and I can't fit them all so they have
over 100 students so we only have 12 of
these hats and jackets which is the
ecology with no apology and I decided if
my lab will I didn't ask their
permission I should have but I would get
one of the last remaining ones because I
think Alan has really been a champion
for ecology in our university so I I do
want to take the opportunity
unfortunately it's only an extra-large
but I think that way you look like you
know so so thanks for being a great
pelvis
Thank You Jenny and I'm happy to take
the credit for things I had very little
to do with but it's really been a
pleasure listening tonight and I'm sure
that members of the audience will have
questions if you're willing sure how are
we doing on time I have a we have time
okay and there will be a reception
afterwards we're here but we'll find
room but so are there any questions
is there any idea of you know preserving
species by rewarding people for doing so
in some sort of monetary way is that
ever crossed any way of monetizing where
I say centralizing people for
deterioration has approximately pieces
not so much giving the money maybe it's
just actually trying to convince them
that there are clear veterans by
yeah I see
relationship between protected areas and
open areas areas of communities actually
work with the same leader in actually
extract resources they need to be doing
this working
and we will try to find rings too
especially modern
it's
the question is about the role of
and we all know that if you leave meat
you're actually
look
so
is that
we're their size
for that
we've been talking about here
for a while
I
I mean here Columbia you you might be
able to correlate our focus on
environmental science with certain
biases to the left I don't know I think
that might be accurate and if you look
at the history of the US we as you
showed in your in your data we've sort
of killed our planes and there weren't
and there were some contrary voices to
it while we were doing it while we were
spreading out agriculturally using new
farming methods you know in couraging
the use of the plow after World War one
so that you know this is as you've said
you're really familiar to us so does do
you find that the science that we now
have describing biodiversity different
advocate advocacy methods allow us to
like I said translate the importance of
biodiversity to people that are really
sort of facing the environment in a
visceral way and trying to get more from
it
that there is something
and after some time do a real-life I've
done it a few times where our big-name
computer
artists
and it starts
some ways that you're not
and I think that we now
or this
single
Levi
you try to be a five-year grant from
do you look at paragraph
there
poverty
courage is sort of a greater
conservation that might be good for
these types of efforts or do you think
that people need more luxury in order to
be able to you know support efforts for
biodiversity or whatever that the
economic collapses is going to be a
problem for environmentalists and for
encouraging this type of ecological
interest and then the second question is
how frequently is sort of population
control brought in to biodiversity or
ecological studies ever it seems that
that people talk about increasing
numbers of PA the pressure that
increasing population brings on on the
environment but that population controls
such a sort of politically charged
subject that it's not really rains
there's a it's a you know part of the
problem Lance if I can get to those
those two are very very complex and
interesting questions the first one was
with this credit crunch coming how
effective are we going to be at trying
to convince people to push the
conservation and environmental agendas
forward it's hard for me to say I'm not
a social scientist I suppose I should
add Steve Cohen because he has more
experience about how we responded to
things like clean air and clean water
and garbage in New York but my sense is
actually that when environmental
problems raise their head come people
will address them independent of what
the economic situation is I think that
if people got the convincing sense that
the preservation of diversity in the
United States was really important to
their well being not necessarily a
pocketbook but through their well-being
you'd be surprised I mean I've been very
impressed how in the United States the
Endangered Species Act has survived some
35 years or something like that through
all kinds of administration's that I've
seen I mean the public will not let go
of this sense that it's important to
save our species from going extinct
my question is my purpose is a different
one which is not to keep them from going
extinct but to see that they can
actually carry out their roles and our
ecosystems and I don't think I don't
think that if we're down on our luck
financially that if somebody points to
need for preserving diversity to stop
the spread of West Nile virus or Lyme
disease that people will actually react
to that and perhaps shift their
priorities about what they're funding
and what they're not funding like 7.5
billion dollars for a healthcare plan
versus 700 billion dollars to bail out
the banks you decide you're on your
second question was quickly mind me I
have a perspective yes yes population um
the the well I'm not I'm not a
demographer or was Jo Jo cone was here
tell me couldn't come tonight and he
would he'd be very quick to say that you
know population isn't something that one
really tries to control and I think it
was a mistake in the early days to
actually refer to it as if we needed to
control population human population
growth is a very complex thing that is
tied into so many different sorts of
feed backs with resources with education
with climate with all kinds of things
with disease with infant mortality that
in fact my sense is that if you can get
your environmental ducks in a row and
you can get your education and health
ducks in a row you'll find that
population probably will get in line as
well that's just maybe that's overly
optimistic but at least there are a lot
of data that suggests that population is
certainly part of the problem but it's
not it's you know it's not that the
environment actually needs to solve be
solved by controlling population but in
fact it's an integrated process of
bringing our economies are an
environment together into one working
system and I think you might find that
it would it would population would start
to to show a change as it already has in
a way that would work well with the
environment but I don't know why my my
spouse is a social scientist in a
historian as she always told me that as
a historian of science not to worry when
we were first courting one another that
until I died I would not relieve any
interest to her and we've been married
for a long time and she has patiently
taught me that scientists frequently
make mistakes about making statements
that really are in the realm natural
scientists of the social scientists
you know the sort of the the managers
the economists the the sociologists the
psychologists the anthropologists sorry
I have my ideas but I know now to to to
let the experts speak on that I think
what I like about working with the
millennium assessment was the first time
we bought together 1300 social and
natural scientists from around the world
to write the millennium assessment
documents what truly did take a clearer
look at population economy natural
processes and if you read their volume
and saw all available free on the web
you'll see that they don't really feel
the population is the biggest thing we
have to deal with and I take them at
their word as as experts in social
sciences that that's the case but you're
right it's a politically charged can I
ask one last question
I mean I'm bringing my bias from the
field of education I'm wondering if you
have looked at the field of education as
you are trying to reach out to as many
segments of the population as possible
particularly at the secondary level how
well these ideas have been integrated
and what is the scope in the near future
thank you I was I was going to show you
a slide I don't think I have it now and
it was a
exactly
yeah it was
are the best questions
don't ya
be better
yeah
where
you know what that speech music
thank you all for coming thank you
Shaheed for a wonderful talk